nobody can be mad at us because we went
on crunch time
when the time came
y'all thought we were just gonna go sit
in the house and you know i'm saying boo
boo cried
no
we still on the same [ __ ] because draco
didn't die you know shoot out no crazy
street [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] we be on
you know what i'm saying he died at work
you know what i'm saying at his job you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] make it seem
like oh he died on something
no he died at work where he felt more
comfortable mm-hmm we didn't die on the
street you know i'm saying he didn't die
on the street period
so as far as the
the program we didn't change nothing
you know i'm saying they expected us to
change the program
no why would we change you know saying
we wasn't doing nothing wrong
yeah i mean
i think like
yeah just what happened man so
unfortunate bro because you would think
like you said
in that type of setting everybody's so
gangsta you're gonna sing [ __ ] just
tripping you know what i'm saying you
would think all the papa's we the idiot
all the shows we did [ __ ] just like
you know what i'm saying
but that's another note yeah was there
any like when you guys uh got to that
show was there any idea that there was
any like like like you guys said you're
at work we wasn't worried about we went
to work you know what i'm saying we
wasn't caring who was there what was
that man we just went to work you know
i'm saying dracula was going to pick up
his money if it was just me him and
one security he wasn't giving [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying would you say that
the
backstage area was a bit
unorganized for five minutes that's what
i mean like that's crazy to think you
guys were there for five minutes and
that popped off so i can only imagine
like in terms of you guys lack of
security security like what we doing i
know security if you ask me [ __ ] i ain't
seen uh
unless it was at the front searching our
security that's the only place i see in
security is that kind of the or like
kind of the premise of
uh your guys's lawsuit just kind of the
lack of security the lack of
organization i wouldn't know [ __ ] that
should be the premise of the you know
thing because that's what it was i
didn't see no security other than
where they checked draco security that
was it